形態到底怎麼看
它可以推測未來股價的走勢
形態有目標價
同樣這個圖拉100張來
有90張都是這樣
都是上漲
想要做股票賺錢
這個就一定要先背起來
這張圖很重要
它有告訴你怎麼進場
怎麼停順
怎麼算目標價
你不要把握機會
如果它來了
就是你的財政業到了
太棒了
我就介紹一個最好的形態
這個叫N字底
N字底
這個生育九成
九成
怎麼可能
你買這個黑黑疊破
然後這個紅可以上去
好 然後又突破了這個上級線
那你買了後果了
大掌
馬上學起來
老師 我們10年前到10年後
這樣重逢
後來就發現
我們兩個都變得還滿受歡迎的
因為人家都覺得說
如果這樣看起來
這10年我們應該都是
我們應該都是往上走
有這樣的感覺嗎
對
可是事實上中間是有高有低的
那當然
人生總是有低潮高潮
你也會有嗎
我看你都一直笑咪咪的
不可能啦
笑咪咪
對外面當然要笑咪咪
這個跟股票市場一樣
都會起起伏伏高高低
像我就是好不容易做這個節目
可是我製作人
他幫我氣個半死之類的
就是也會有低潮
沒關係啦
他罵你就不用瘋狂
然後因為我們的低潮跟他的低潮不一樣
不一樣
對 他有他的低潮
對
每個人都有壓力
這種股票也會遇到壓
預壓就回來一下
好
但是今天主導是要教我們的是
不管在股底或是在山上
其實人生風景不一樣
沒錯
股票的風景也不一樣
就算你看懂現在在股底
還是在山峰
在山峰也不要太高興
因為那個風很大
基地咕嚕滾下去
那在山底你也不要失望
因為你有很大的這個空間
可以去奮鬥
去往上爬
今天的理財大人秀
標古在線等我們現在
最受歡迎的一個單元
大家敲碗引緊期待的是什麼呢
叫做形態
剛剛老師有講了
大家人生是不是都有在谷底
或是有在山頭的時候呢
但是坐谷票有一個好消息
你在谷底有谷底的風景
你在山頭有山頭的風景
做法是不一樣的
但是都有路可以走喔
那形態一直是技術分析裡面
一個非常非常重要的指標
一個關卡喔 問不說關卡
照好每次看形態
都覺得也太難了
還記得嗎
之前有蔡森大神來講形態
現在我們請最平易敬人的
朱教授老師
告訴你形態到底怎麼看
但是呢到底什麼叫形態啊
好懸喔
對 形態很多人搞不清楚啊
其實形態簡單的解釋
它就是盤整
盤整 對
盤整不喜歡
因為盤整會有不同的圖形出來
那我們在講區域的時候
盤整是最難做的
對啊
因為它正在做形態
有時候多空雙巴也是盤整
它正在做形態
因為不同的阻力
不同的環境
不同的區式
可會做出很多不同的形態
這些形態其實我們一般來說
是經過大數據的去統計的
大數法則
對 大陸法則
它叫做先途的長相
而且各位要知道
在歐美的股票歷史很久了
好幾百年了
不是我們台灣那麼幾十年而已
那幾百年一定發生過很多的圖
所以它就用
所有長相一樣的圖
它就去做統計
這不是算命的一樣的意思
對 一樣的命牌
有點像那個看面相一樣對不對
對
老師我看你就大富大貴
好 謝謝了
那我們的形態就是
盤整出來的一個圖形
是
一個固定的圖形
那這個圖形它再經過去統計
比如說它統計了一萬張
都是這個圖一模一樣的
那結果它就會發現一個定律
比如說這裡面有九千張
都會走相同的那個路徑
就是未來的走法
那這樣它就可以做一個統計
這個形態很好
也就是說十張有九張都會往上走
都會達到目標
這樣子我們就有學習的價值了
因為你有高的勝率
我們就值得來做參考
所以他可以推測未來股價的走勢
那學型態兩個目的
第一個目的就是找機會
因為我們在股票市長一直跟大家講
你學那麼多在幹嘛
就是說這邊有機會
你可以賺錢
所以型態也是一個機會
如果是底部型態確認你是不是就有機會了
因為這個型態有統計過
它會漲到哪裡
那你就有目標價
所以最重要你多懂的一個型態
你就多了一個機會
你就多出來一個機會
我覺得這很棒
因為現在叫做數位時代
大家都是大數據統計
事實上技術線圖裡面的型態
它就是一個大數據的統計
這個圖形的統計
好 可說大家在學型態的時候
要稍微注意一下
入門的四個型態
我剛剛有講型態很好
你可以發現機會
那你一定會抓到機會
趕快想賺錢
但是因為它是一個大數法則
所以它並不是百分之百的
因為經過統計
百分之九十會到
還有百分之十是不會到的
其實我們學投資任何方法
都不要以為百分之百
都沒有百分之百
但是勝率儘量提高
但是不同的形態勝率會不一樣
有些形態很好
勝率很高
那你就儘量做那種形態
失敗的機率比較小
那我們還有
我們即使找到一個好的形態
我們在操作的時候還是一樣
你的風險控制好
是
停損還是要做
如果你萬一碰到
百分之十的失敗率的話
那你又有大賠
那就不符合我們前面上課講的
我們前面上課大家
真的很感動
很多粉絲
都是一看再看
都看好幾遍
幾十遍
對 他都幾乎把它會背了
他幾乎會背了
所以停損一定要做
第三個
形態跟一般的
我們在操作有什麼區別
有一個很大的區別
型態有目標價
可以來計算可能的目標價
對 它有一個統計的目標價
就是剛剛講的統計
這個圖形大部分都會長到哪裡
所以它有一個目標價
所以它可以有一個型態的目標價
但這個目標價不是絕對會到
所以我們在操作都
像我們上一期講支撐壓力
也跟大家講了
它不一定會到壓力
但也許會過壓力 對不對
因為它很強啊
所以那個就做一個形態的目標
就當一個你這個操作的目標
你的參考
那你的操作還是我們回到講要有紀律
你就收你的紀律操作
有可能他會超過目標
你就賺很多
那如果你不守紀律
結果你就沒賺
你以為到了目標我就趕快賣
結果你就賣掉了
等於這個目標並不是100%會到
所以我們可以先預設一個參考值
可是一切按照紀律的進出
按照紀律操作
那形態你如果在日線有日線的形態
那如果你是看周線圖就有周線的形態
那形態都一樣 長相都一樣
只是因為你看周線
所以你要在周線去算目標價
你看到日線的你就在日線算目標價
所以不要看日線算周線
不要看周線算月線這都不對
那也許你在周線看到一個形態
那它都比它設100塊
這個形態的目標會到130
那這個時候你要操作
那你要回到日線來
操作的時候反而要先來看
你要在日線切進去
我在周線
算目標
型態跟目標
對
可是我操作時要回到日線來看
對 比如說你要長這個三成
那不可能一次就到
對
所以你在日線裡面
長長疊疊
這樣子去做到目標
這樣子去注意一下型態
好 到底型態有幾種呢
我們講型態型態
是一個大的範圍
那型態很多
不會吧 老師
我們沒有那麼多時間啦
這個不多啦
這還不多
在真正的形態學
我先講形態
當然我剛剛有講
是國外去統計的
對
因為他們的數據夠嘛
那統計出來的這種圖形
就是盤整整理的圖形
大概有
哇 大概五六十種
不是 外國人這樣就不誠懇
對
星座就十二個
對不對
黃道就十二公
沒有嘛
他為什麼是這裡
裹票市場變化太大了嘛
操作的人變化太多
但是我們整理起來
最重要的大概就這20幾種
這邊大概11個
這邊10個
這邊5 6個
20幾個
就只有20幾種
就只有20幾個
太多了
20幾個不多啦
我現在要幫散戶發聲
等一下老師要告訴我們
最重要的
當然
20幾種還是很多
那因為當然
那個節目的時間不可能嘛
20幾個
我先把型態的分類給大家講
那在一個形態分兩大類
一個叫反轉
一個叫敘事
反轉一聽就知道嘛
一個底部一個頭部嘛
對 底部的話就是回升叫反轉
反轉變多
頭部就往下就要反轉
就要變空頭了
那還有一個敘事是走在一半
是
我們趨勢常常走一半就不走了
但它也沒有跌下來
那就是盤整嘛
那盤整
那這個時候的盤整
如果再繼續往上突破
那我們就叫敘事
敘原來的方向
原來是多
這個形態完了繼續走多
那這個就是敘事
我們用圖解來讓大家看看形態長怎樣
來看
那這個是不是在打底的
現在看的是底部形態裡面說的一個什麼
雙糊底
我們剛才那個十二十一個裡面都有
雙糊底這個是圓糊底
那我們來看一下頭部呢
頭部也有啊
這你在剛才那個造法講的頭肩頂
頭肩頂是指這邊是肩膀嗎
對這是左肩 這是右肩
那你看一疊破就開始疊了
但是你的目標價不會一直到
它有可能還會反彈
但反彈你又準備可以空了
因為它已經是空頭了嘛
所以你就做空
同學一定會問
那跟我平常做有什麼區別
我平常這個頭頭滴滴滴
我也是做空啊
對啊
形態混在K線裡面
對啊 那我為什麼要懂形態
那我剛剛有講形態有目標啊
形態可以算目標價
對 它有參考目標價
它可以到目標 讓你
只要它趨勢沒改 你可以一直抱啊
你不一定要在這裡反彈補啊
因為它空頭沒有改嘛
應該說如果我們看到頭頭高或頭頭低
我們只知道趨勢是這樣
趨勢是改的
可是我不曉得要怎麼算我的目標價
目標價 那就在形態了
所以形態最重要就是有個目標價
老師雖然我自己略有設列
所以知道這要投間定
然後可能也猜這個叫什麼
有弧度吧 是叫雙弧底
這邊有兩個弧度
這個叫圓弧
可是我現在就看圖說故事
可不可以告訴我
讓我學會精通一個最重要的
沒有 我今天
因為時間我就介紹一個
最好的形態
最好的形態 有分好壞
最好的
壞的就是其實各位最熟悉
剛才照好要講
怎麼WD對不對
WD是最不好的形態
為什麼
形態裡面成功率最低的
那為什麼大家都在講
只有四成
那現在有在講WD老師
你們生率只有四成
因為大家只認得這個WD
所以WD要成功率高
要配合我們講過的均線
你要均線多排
否則你WD出不來的
你賺不到他的錢
那WD生率四成老師你現在教我
我這個生率九成
九成?
有生率九成的形態
當然
所以型態十幾個
你要知道哪個好哪個不好
是
所以以後你學了你就專門做那個好型態
對啊
如果他來了就是你的
怎麼講財神也到了
太棒了
二十幾個型態裡面我只要學一個
各位一定急喔
趕快要急
我告訴你
今天告訴大家一個很好的型態
這個叫N字笛
N字笛
很多人把這個型態誤會
當作W字笛
因為他有兩個腳
W字笛是不兩個腳
對啊
像W嗎
英文的W嗎
但是他也是兩個角
但這兩個角的英文不是W
他叫N
這一個角跟這一個角
他叫N字底
今天我就介紹一個最好的
成功率最高的
那我在講這個之前
我先講一下
N字底是底部的反轉形態
他不是中繼
他不會在中間
所以N字底一定是底部反轉
中間我們回後上漲
那個就不是N字底
OK啦 我先講
N字底其實就像我們在上樓梯一樣
一上一回一上一回就越跑越高
我們在底部就是最開始上樓梯的地方
那個地方如果出現了這種圖形
N字底是一個圖形
出現了這個圖形 你要把握機會
老師 像你這樣畫
真的會讓人覺得
這不是WU底嗎
為什麼是N字底
我們來慢慢的解說
N字底是不是有兩個角
這兩個角有特殊的定義
你一定要符合這個材色N字底
如果沒有符合就不是
我們先看第一隻腳很容易找
任何空頭反彈都叫第一隻腳
只要空頭的反彈
第一檔出現大量成交量
長紅可以反彈
上了五軍又突破昨天的高點
我們在空頭都叫反彈
疊了一波都會反彈
反彈完了現在第二隻腳最重要
這個第二隻腳要符合這個條件
其實第一隻腳很容易
第一檔大量
長紅可以反彈上五軍突破了前日最高
就在往上走了
那這時候空頭反彈完了是不是要疊了
那這時候疊如果不破前滴就是第二隻腳
前面滴點沒有破就第二隻腳
那他沒有破可是有條件
下跌不能超過反彈的1.2
老師有特別寫第二隻叫做高腳
它不能是低腳
低腳就WD
也不能平腳
下跌不能超過
剛剛那個反彈幅度的1分之1
我們這個第一隻腳是不是在反彈
假如反彈了10塊錢
你現在回來不能超過跌回5塊
你如果跌回5塊的第二隻腳就不是了
就是歸到WD
所以是比較高的腳
所以這個是一定要的符合
不然就不是
那開始指疊轉折向上
就是沒有疊超過1月2就上 向上
那向上剛才上漲的第一隻腳
下來上面是不是有一個高點
有一個高點
上漲突破這個高點
N字底就確認
就是他下疊不能超過前面漲幅的1月2
再上需要突破上一個高點
一突破就確認
這樣才能叫N字底
所以我們如果你有反彈第一隻腳
你的第一隻腳的最低點
我們就畫一條直撐
那你反彈上去是不是下來了
你上面就畫一個壓力
直撐壓力又來了
只要壓力一過
N字底就完成
這樣子很清楚
用聽得很清楚 圖形來看看
現在我就解釋囉
任何的反彈都是第一隻腳
可是這個下跌沒有了
第一隻腳破了
那現在就看另外一個第一隻腳
等於是假的
因為他這樣下跌
剛講都不能二分之一嘛
對 不算重新起身
來 現在反彈
下跌
二分之一沒有破
上來了
哎呦
這個時候第二隻腳就出來了
所以我們反彈
當他下修時
我們先畫一個二分之一
待在哪裡
對
只要他沒有跌破二分之一
然後要再上漲
對
好 那這個也是我們前面各位複習
這個叫底底高
哦 你出了
你是多頭走勢
你出了一個腳比前面的高了
所以這個都比前面低嘛
對
對不對
現在盤整 底底高進盤整
所以你中間的高點一突破
這個形態就確認
N字底的形態就確認
剛剛講的嘛
上漲了
下來沒有突破
他分機上去突破了這個高點
這個位置N字底就完了
完成了
就N字底好
我們看一個實際股票
因為那個畫起來很好看
來
大家看懂嗎
這一隻疊那現在是不是反彈
那是不是在五日軍線上
是 所有的反彈都在五日軍線上
那這跟黑黑是不是跌破了
那現在高點出來了
這個上景線
那現在跌破我不知道是跌1天
5天8天不曉得
不確定
可是這個紅K
這個紅K各位看到了嗎
紅K有沒有上來
有 上五軍過了昨天的高點
剛才那張板子上有寫
那這就是第二隻腳
那第二隻腳來囉
所以你的上景線一突破形態就缺了
老師我覺得有一點點難捏
第一腳我覺得是很容易的
可是到這邊它就有出現一些來來回回
沒有啊 五日均線不要忘了
就一直沿著五日均線
它是站在上面對不對
可是這邊有跌破
這個黑K跌破
但跌破沒有超過上漲幅度的1分
它又上去了
然後這個紅K上去了
然後又突破了這個上景線
這個N字頂就完成
那剛剛講這是不是機會
是
那你買了後果了
大漲
不是大漲
對不對
圖上已經
這個就是統計
因為我同樣這個圖拉100張來
有90張都是這樣
都是上漲
那還有10張呢
我就守好停損
把停損守好
所以等於是說
如果還有10張
是他到景仙又下去
那可能就沒有成形囉
就沒有成形
所以你就趕快怎麼樣
去停損就好了
所以我在這個地方
就順便說明一下
這個怎麼操作
剛才已經看懂了
現在來操作
我們剛剛說這個回來
沒有跌破1分之1
那這裡有個紅K上來
那這個就是N字底的第二支腳
但還沒有確認
對不對 過高才確認
還沒有過高之前都不能確認
那你可以在這裡做4單
比如說你要買3張
你先買1張嘛
我先試試看
為什麼這個可以4單
因為我剛剛講
這個型態百分之90都會完成
都會完成這個型態
所以你可以先試單
那如果你在這試單
是不是也要控制好風險
控制好風險就是這個低點不要破
要破了就滴滴滴啦
就變空頭總是了
我們的趨勢馬上就趕了
它型態會掉了
對你就把它這個低點
那如果你在這裡不試單
你說因為滴滴高還沒有頭頭高
那你就等型態確認
型態確認你買了還是要守停損
那這時候就是你買進的K線不要跌破
剛才我們那張圖不是買了嗎
下面不要跌破
我覺得很特別的是
老師因為覺得這樣的形態
勝率高 反而可以建議大家在
這個往上走的過程就是單
比較少看到老師這樣說
因為你已經看懂了
你已經知道這是一個N字底的第二隻腳
而且它是高勝率的形態
所以這邊我就不會叫你W底的第二個腳買
因為打飛機的第二個角度很難成功
這個很容易成功
那你做的話你就把它設好停順
那事單一定要懂
不是叫你大買狂買
先買個三分之一的單
對 還沒有確認
那如果你買了成功了
那你就把其他的再買進去就好
好 OK
所以這個點我們就知道囉
可以先是站上去了也可以再買
也可以保守的人等
確定成型再買
那剛剛講恩智禮為什麼好
我們來看一下
剛剛有講 墨標價
剛才那張圖是不是長了一大段
其實那一段你早就知道了
怎麼可能
你買的時候就知道你可以賺到那一段
哪有 怎麼可能只知道會往上漲
因為那個就是目標價
怎麼算
目標價很容易算
從第二隻腳的旗漲
第二隻腳從這邊
這邊漲多少
就跟你第一隻腳漲多少是一樣
你第一隻腳反彈多少
它就漲多少
所以是一個等服的概念
這個叫正波段預測法
我前面這一波就跟這一波是一樣的
這一波如果長20塊
應該也長20塊
從它的低點
比如說這個低點是100
100長到120
可是你回來不可能跌破20
不能再跌回100
應該是跌到1001就要上去了
你110就上來
所以你從110再加20塊
所以你就會跑到130去了
你就會過這個高碼
就會跑到130
那這個就是我們的目標價
好 形態知道怎麼形成了
也知道他的第二個角的重點
然後也知道他的目標價
也知道進場位置
也知道如何停止
好像這個形態
好像現在下課買股票
但是要講的目標價是參考
沒錯
他不見得也有可能沒有等幅上去
剛剛新法有講
目標價也可能抽過
你可能賺得比你想的還要多
這是第一隻腳
這是第二隻腳
這是確認
所以第一隻腳到高點
第二隻腳到目標價
第一隻腳的反彈
下來再重複一次
沒有過這個反彈的部分之一
沒有跌破就上去又過前高
所以就是等幅來算目標價
那這個就是目標價
那你在第二隻腳試單
那這個就是停順點
下面的第一點
你在紅K買
那紅K的第一點叫停順點
所以這張大家可能要螢幕拍照拍下來
這個叫紀律
紀律
對
你想要做股票賺錢
這個就一定要先背起來
這張圖很重要
他有告訴你怎麼進場
怎麼停順
怎麼算目標加益
全部都在這張圖
只是這個型態成功率很高
所以有才介紹給你們
我們看實物實戰
從這個觀念
各位可不可以自己去推算一下
你想要賺一個N字底多賺一點
那是不是這個反彈要高一點
對啊 不然我的目標叫做彈三塊
對 但是你的目標就很少啊
沒錯
所以你想要
你想要
所以你同樣都找到N值底
你是不是要找一個
這個反彈越高的N值底越好
對 因為這樣我第二段的等幅
才有的賺啊
第二段你才會賺得多
這就是我們選股的另外一個訣竅
大家都在選股票
為什麼有人賺得多
有人賺得少
有人選都圖好
選得型態好
老師你讓我又思考一下
不是形態出來就一定好
沒錯
他也要等距的這個漲幅夠大
因為你要做目標價
好 那我們來看
這個回跌是不是二分之一沒有跌破
對
然後這個紅K是不是第二隻腳
那這個是不是確認
是
那你一算目標價只到這個地方
對
那後來是不是到了
是
他到了
可是你不是做得很辛苦
很辛苦
而且這個目標價很小
對啊
如果我們從這個算50塊好了
這個地方也不少
也是有十幾塊
這邊50塊到65塊
不行 十幾塊太少了
到62塊
我們看標股在現等
標股的第一三成以上
這是底 後面還有
可是這等得很辛苦
一直等等
好 那我們就換一支股票桌
都是底部
我講N字底在底部
我們來換一支
那這個反彈是不是就很夠
對
彈了十幾天 20天
那現在我就盯著你
因為你這個叫反彈不是多頭
我現在就可以鎖你了
我鎖你回來
我把二分之一先畫好
因為這個已經發生了
所以你就畫好
你一看到這個紅K
來了 什麼來了
就是N字底的往上的
四單位置來了
然後再加一個
伺服在月線上
可以了
雖然它不是多頭
它是底底高
而且它好像也在這邊
也是站上五日軍嗎
上五日軍
然後過昨天高點
四單
好
你四單就可以算目標價了
因為你有低點了嘛
對
那這個
所以你漲到這
所以你就會漲到這
你已經知道你大概可以賺到多少錢了
所以你在這邊四單
就知道有可能到這邊囉
對 目標價已經出了
然後等到確立
也有可能繼續漲
沒有把其他的都買進去
然後一樣
你把停損守好
對
看到沒有
停損沒有破
沒有跌破
然後來
目標價到囉
第二天不漲就請你差不多了
就到了
雖然後面還有
但我們不要貪心
因為他到目標價是回跌的
應該要出場了
後面我們就
同學又會問
剛才這個小編也在問
後面這個是不是N字底
他回來沒有二分之一
沒有跌破二分之一
因為如果往這邊看
上去A回來又上去
是不是 可是他不在底部
形態上來說
所以他不是N字底
這你不會到目標價
他就是多頭回後買上漲
因為你是多頭啊
所以你還是可以買啊
然後你跌破賣
你還是賺錢
但是你不可能再
向目標價就算
但是這樣的話
我們是守均線嘛
就守機率
也許你這一次就一直漲啊
目標價可能還超過一倍
你就按機率
所以剛才有交代
所以這張來看
相對來說空間就比較大
對 你同樣時間都在兩個底部
找到N字底 請你做這個
這個你獲利比較好
空間比較大
這就是同學學完了東西
要舉一反三 自己再去思考
我已經懂了這個形態
那哪一個是最好
你當然要對你有利的嘛 對不對
而且你要知道你反彈越高
你一定均線都突破
對不對 你的均線都突破嘛
所以你比較強
其實老師在上集講
那個支撐跟壓力的時候
應該上上集
有講說最好就是
它的壓力在很高的地方
對 離你遠一點
離你越遠 你長上去
才不會預壓嘛
其實各位我解釋一下你就懂了
第二個
你這個N字底
我剛剛講1⁄1
那如果你回來1⁄1呢
那就比回來1⁄1的卡牌
還要強
所以就更好嗎
當然啊
所以到底很簡單
你看這個為什麼那麼強
因為你只回來一個黑K
對 它事實上沒有觸到
真的到二分之一就上去
所以這個就更強
這個N字底就更強
理由很簡單
因為你只有這一根黑K套牢
是
如果你再多疊你就三天被套牢
那你套牢的人少
所以你功很容易就過了
很容易把大家一起拉上去了
就很強嘛 就很強
就回檔越小的股票越強
好
就不能超過二分之一來
但是如果你回來是四分之一
那就比二分之一還要強
其實就像老師講的
股票常常是主力在作價
沒錯
那如果今天想作價的人多
回檔不太可能升
就馬上就要上去了
這個道理大家慢慢去體會
你就知道以後你做股票
你就會發現很容易就很好做
以前老師做不到
或者是奇怪了就漲一點點
所以你要選強的股票
好 但是我們常常聽完朱老師講
其實非常多人都講說
朱老師是他們遇過在技術分析上
講得最讓人家懂的
可是你真的聽懂了嗎
今天我們有小心機
我們要來考你有沒有聽懂
朱老師來隨堂考一下我們的N字敵
第一個我們先看趨勢
這是空頭反彈
沒錯吧
是
反彈完了現在在等什麼
等他回跌有沒有超過2分之1
對 等到第二支腳
可是老師我有疑問他
你看這個反彈是不是上月仙
上機線了是不是很強
可是老師為什麼不在這邊找
這是空頭啊
空頭的下面就叫底
所以我們就看這一段就好了
我們要底部反轉就是空轉多
這個才叫底部反轉
其實趙華真的很厲害
你看這是不是底
你說是底嘛
對 因為如果我以長線看這邊更低
那請問這個底是不是反彈
那這個是會回答
那這根紅K是什麼
上漲突破
N字底啊
就是N字底
對不對
因為這邊沒有疊超過他的二分之一
那請問這個N字底
你這邊這一段是不是長到這邊來了
這一段的漲幅等幅長到這邊
對啊 就是你從這裡
從這裡 從這個低點嘛
對 長到這啊
對 這就是N字底啊
因為趙華的一問就是說
如果這個圖拉比較長來看
他這邊感覺這樣底部
這邊我就有一點小狐狸
就是說他跟這邊比有點高呢
我們所謂的底部就是
空頭轉多的
那個下面都叫底部
所以你一定要這邊是空
這邊一定要空頭
空頭現在反彈嘛
所以這個地之角
你也不能做多
那現在就等第二之角
所以我現在要看
它是從大概199塊左右長到110
所以它現在回來
它可能不能跌破
不能長過1.2
因為這個還不一定
也許明天還會漲
對不對
所以你要另外再算
算到有一天它跌下來
你就開始算了
好 開始等這個位置
這張圖是老師找出來
讓大家可以先鎖股什麼叫鎖股
鎖定這支股票
當作功課
那同樣的
那如果他回來跌破二分之一
你就不是N字底囉
就不是了
也不能再來找我算帳
我說老師這個不是N字底嗎
沒關係 我們播出的時候
請各位同學留言好不好
留言在就是播出當天
這一檔股票到底有沒有形成N字底
有還是沒有留言給我們喔
好 這樣大家去做功課
第一檔考試沒關係 回去再看
第二檔是反彈
這個是空碼
這個沒問題嘛
所以這個也是底部
對
這個也是底部
對不對 因為已經疊很久了
那現在反彈是不是上月線
對
那現在月線還沒疊破
那其實它已經回來了
是
那回來就是二分之一
還沒
還沒破
但是也還沒站上去
對 但是破了
你就這個就不是N字底了
但是站上去
如果紅K上了
上了季線了
因為你這邊再等兩天 機線就下來了
那如果你再來一個像這樣的紅K
上來那是不是就N字底
他現在有點是反彈 後來在那邊盤整
對
他沒有破1.2
然後再上漲
但是這一段的漲幅
以趙華來看沒有很多
沒有很喜歡
已經解釋過了
他的長相沒有很帥
對
趙華反應太快
馬上就學會了
馬上學起來
剛才已經交過了
開玩笑
剛才我們有兩張
有一張很很好
有一張就不設很好
但是你大概都沒有停損
所以你們有停損就叫成功
所以這個成功率就有100%
我兩張都賺到了
所以是100%
所以這一張雖然漲幅
就好像漲相沒有很帥
但老師也幫你找出來
還是可以鎖住它
可以鎖住
看來看後續有沒有走到
像老師講的N字底
我想今天這個N字底
講得非常的清楚
這種形態下面各位隨時鎖
你所到了就是你的
這邊也有啊
你看這個書是上來
這書是回來 沒有破1分之1
在月線上 又上去
然後就到這
因為你就只有這一段嘛
所以這個就到這
那後面呢 回後買上漲
回後買上漲
好
各種不同老師教的技巧
其實在同一張圖裡面都可以運用哦
N字底走完其實怎麼樣
嚴軍線操作嘛
N字底走完你還可以回後買上漲
其實老師都有講過哦
但是今天的金鷹班
不要忘記了
我們金鷹班叫做
隱藏的第二隻腳
還有隱藏的N字底
什麼每次都會有隱藏版
所以我們金鷹班
等一下會來告訴他
還有更進階的隱藏版
這邊趙華要來預告兩件事情
真的要仔細來聽好喔
就是第一件事情
請大家幫我們恭喜啦
李才達人秀
在11月2號禮拜一
要改成所謂的
週一到週五的晚間電視節目
而且我們會在57台東森財經新聞台
晚上的8點到8點半
每一天你都可以看到理財達人秀
當然我們播完之後
也會把節目通通放到YouTube上面
所以支持我們的觀眾朋友
打開一下電視
禮拜一到禮拜五
詐謊每天都可以陪你囉
好開心喔
那第二個就是非常謝謝大家
對我們精英班長期的支持
不過其實在很早之前
可能今年的3 4月吧
趙浩友講說
其實金櫻班的100塊是一個早鳥價
那因為大家實在太踴躍了
所以一直到現在
我們都沒有去調整他的價格
可是非常不好意思的是
因為我們老師真的太佛心
我們不能用這樣的籌勞來對待老師
所以在11月11號開始
我們的金櫻班的100塊裡面
會開始沒有內容
那怎麼辦 沒有內容
大家去哪裡看
不好意思 我們會全面請大家
升等到榮耀班去看內容好不好
榮耀班裡面會有我們所有老師
教學的進階內容
也會有不定期的直播
我知道很多人反應最近直播比較少
會的以後會逐步的恢復
但是請記得11月11號之後
我們100塊的基因班裡面
其實純粹你還是可以進來
但是舊的影片
以及如果你想要對這個頻道有支持
很歡迎你們
懂內100塊錢
但如果你們要繼續學習
繼續上課的話
請升級到300塊錢的榮耀班
好的
預告的事情有點多
請大家可以回看一下
那今天老師教我們
怎麼樣去看形態
形態其實最重要的就有20幾種
但老師從20幾種裡面交出了
N字底
為什麼
勝率可能高達9成
但是不要忘記
勝率是給你參考的啦
如果上去他沒有形成
真正的N字底的時候
平損 紀律一定要做好
那今天理財當然就就到這邊囉
我們下次再見 拜拜